well commit the Clark County School
District soon be looking for a new
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara announcing
he's in the running for a job in Florida
Jara issued a statement that he is being
considered to lead the Broward County
School District which includes Fort
Lauderdale now that statement reads in
part after being urged to apply I'm
honored to be considered for the
superintendent position in Broward
County Florida Clark County is my home
and I'm committed to this community and
our kids as I informed the CCSD Board of
Trustees I will remain as superintendent
to continue the work I started five
years ago
but those five years have been Rocky
jara's tenure with the district has been
clouded with controversy since he took
the job in June of 2018. in October of
21 the Board of Trustees voted to remove
him but then just weeks later they
changed their mind and brought him back
then last October the school board voted
in favor of giving him a contract
extension with the 76 thousand dollar
annual raise now there's a chance that
he'll still leave for a different School
District